here are the nominees for best animated
short film
affairs of the art joanna quinn and les
mills festia hugo covarrubias and devo
diaz
box ballet anton diaco
robin robin dan o'jari and mikey please
the windshield wiper alberto mielgo and
leo sanchez
and the oscar goes to
the windshield wiper
okay uh well there is no swearing here
sorry um
uh okay animation is an art that
includes every single art that you can
imagine
uh animation for adults is a fact uh
it's happening
let's call it cinema okay
we killed it a few years back we love
different robots we opened a wide range
of possibilities of what we can do with
this this year the five
nominees they are
non-commercial or
mainstream in terms of the look and four
of them are
adult cinema basically so i'm very
honored because
this is just the beginning of what we
can do with animation
thank you
wait wait wait
i want to dedicate this award to the art
of animation
and
and i just want to second that and also
thank thank you to all the team that has
been involved on this project to make it
happen starting with alberto and his
vision it's it's just amazing
and thank you to the academy for this
award it's just incredible so thank you
very much muchisimas gracias
[Applause]